okay you're in our life
right good evening to everybody good
evening to the members and uh the
council officers and the guests that are
here tonight
um
and we've got a full agenda tonight
and as you will know that this is
streaming live
um so we'll just go through the agenda
uh attendances
um
have there been any apologies
apologies
apologies have been received from
councillor weston and also from um
council win stanley
thank you
item two
is minutes um
to receive the minutes
are we
are we okay with those minutes
yeah
um i already emailed about the minutes
about
um the the questions that were raised
about current and relief right right
weren't all included in the minutes i
thought it was important that they were
yeah i think
you i know you emailed us on that and um
i think
we're aware that all of them are not in
in the minute so we
we will need to add those
in into the minutes um
and then approve through the next
meeting yeah
okay
so it's everybody's happy
uh apart from that
which has been now noted um
item
three is declarations of interest if uh
any members have any declarations of
interest can you please
reveal now
okay
uh item four
is questions from the public which i
don't have any
and
item five we come on to the substantial
items um this is to consider a report
from the trafford housing trust
and we did
you'll recall we did invite
sean anthony as the chair of tht and
larry gold as the chief executive
they've given their apologies tonight
and
in their place
there's
graham scott
and
the executive director of development
and andrew elderly
who is the director of property services
okay
right so we've received a
response
which i think has been circulated it was
circulated late because we only got it
late
but there's a series of
concerns that members had
and you recall at the
last meeting we did have a
representative from a resident who lives
in one of the courts
um
and
um
there was quite a few questions we did
um identify those questions and
um
when we invited
uh the chief executive and the chair
uh we
uh listed the issues that
uh was raised
um so a written report has come
and
i don't know whether
you you would wish to just speak to to
to to this i think mr stevenson was
the resident
within one of the courts um he did say
that he would
be coming i think it's going to get him
how is he going to get him right so it
might be worth just waiting till to till
he does come
because i think it's worth
him
you know hearing what you've got to say
as well
yeah that that's fine we'll just say
we'll just wait for
mr stevenson
right so we're just on this item and
we've just been introducing it and
i think
to tht representatives
um graham i think is going to
just say a few words
[Music]
great okay
and thank you chair and thank you for
the committee of inviting tonight it's
always a pleasure to turn out and um
talk to you and sort of share where we
are um i suppose just before i start off
giving that update i think we've been
here a number of times i'll talk about
the towel blocks and probably just start
off with an apology because it has taken
us a long time to get here we recognize
that
um we're not the only organization in
the country dealing with this issue
though and there's still a large number
of toe blocks out there in the hundreds
that haven't been remediated so we do
believe we're now getting to a positive
position in terms of ourselves in
traffic i just wanted to give a bit
further information on that
so to start off with um
as of prior to christmas we completed
four of the blocks and had the
scaffolding removed from those blocks um
the only one which hadn't been completed
was clifford court
and the difficulty we've had there
is that in terms of when they've we've
received the panels they've been a
slightly longer um which has further
delayed us on there um which is very
unfortunate and we recognize that causes
further disruption for those customers
and our tenants and creates problems
because obviously that scaffolding is up
longer than we would ever want it to be
up so again we do apologize for that and
because of this issue we have been
looking at interim solutions and we have
got a plan now where we can get those
panels replaced for the 15th of april
and get the scaffolding script stripped
and
removed but what that will mean is we
will have to revisit clifford court to
just replace the panels or some of the
panels with the final solution but we
can do that for a mobile solution to
disrupt to limit the disruption to those
customers so the positive news is as of
the 15th of april
all the scaffolding will be moved from
those blocks but this month in time it
is down from four and down to the lower
level on the on the fifth
in terms of customer communications i
know this is one that comes up again and
again and it is vitally important to us
that we we keep our customers informed
we have we have undertaken a number of
measures to try and do that and we would
never pretend that we've been perfect in
this and we never we never get
everything right but we really have
tried to communicate with the customers
to the best of our ability and to do
that we have a high-rise living panel
where we meet with customer
representatives from across those blocks
to gain their views and information on
what we're doing and make sure we
consult and involve them in what we're
doing and whilst it's been difficult
through covered we've had eight of those
sessions virtually and we're about to
move back to having those face-to-face
again which we think will be a big
advantage towards those customers but in
addition to that just to try and give
you an indication of the communication
we have done
um during the last sort of year and a
half two years what has been going on we
have done 14 individual letters to
customers informing of where we are with
the scaffolding and we've done 15
general letters on building safety those
customers so they've nearly had 30
letters of communication within that
period of time
in addition to that we have got notice
boards up in all the blocks and we have
recently put tvs with messages we can
change regularly to keep presence really
up to date with what's going on so we
really have tried to keep them up to
date but again not been perfect but
we've done our best on doing that
in that time we've also respond to
individual residents queries and
questions and complaints this was a
point i would like to make within the
last year and a half we have actually
only had 13 formal complaints in
relation to the towers and not all
relations to works so we you know whilst
we have had complaints we take each one
of those seriously
we haven't had a large number of
complaints from over the 455 customers
who live in those blocks
um
and what we've also done in that time is
we have tried to minimize disruption but
again we do recognize that it has been a
difficult time for those customers in
the blocks and in their homes because
they have had scaffolding up they have
had workmen outside their properties
that does create noise it does create
dust so it's not been perfect but like
all the other organizations in the
country we've had to get to a position
where we solve this and keep our
customers safe and keeping our customers
safe is always our primary objective
as well just a couple of points to
finish on before we happen to take
questions is in addition to this we do
work across all our properties in terms
of high rise general needs and walk up
flat sheltered to keep those safe and we
are part of national bodies and the
national steering group which involves
the minister for building safety and we
do lead on a number of discussions to
make sure with the forefront and we're
doing the right things
in addition to that we do have national
accreditation for the work we do in
terms of fire risk and building safety
who do check we're doing all the right
things and we are involved in another
number of sub forums as well but i
suppose the most important point to make
is that throughout this process we
always have worked very closely with the
fire service
and we have got a primary authority
partnership agreement with the fire
service
which in essence means that they will
talk to us on a regular basis they'll
come out and visit the blocks with us
are unannounced and they'll check the
work they're doing and check they are
comfortable with where we are and what
we're doing to keep our customers safe
and throughout that time we have worked
and we have done what they have asked us
to do so at no point have we worked
against the fire service we have always
worked with them to make sure that our
customers are safe so
i suppose just to conclude yes it's very
unfortunate
it's not something we ever wanted to go
back and visit and redo but we've
recognized the importance of doing that
we have gone back at our cost and the
cost of our contractors to resolve that
we haven't looked to charge leaseholders
in this we've made the positive decision
to go out and just remedy those works
and i suppose the real positive is as of
a couple of weeks time we will be in the
position where all the works are
concluded we're subject to going back to
clifford court and just replacing a few
of those panels which have come back as
i said in the wrong corner
probably that's enough from me and happy
to take any questions
yeah thank you thank you for that update
um
can you give a categorical assurance
that the dates you've mentioned will be
stuck to because i think we've heard
this and residents have heard this
before
where dates have been given and then
have slipped
um
one can understand the covid disruption
but i think at this stage it needs to be
categorical
um just another small point i think we
need a bit more detail
in what you've sent us here
um
for instance i mean you've
you've indicated it says here
progressing the setup of sub forums to
support the high-rise living forum to
progress specific issues of interest to
our customers that doesn't mean anything
to me that's that's the jargon
that needs to we need some proper
information here consulted on options
regarding support for individual
customers i mean again that's clever
working i can consult on options for
anything i fancy but i mean i'm going to
do it
um i think we need some real
you know some real black and white
proposals in here on what you're
actually going to do rather than words
like progressing and consulting thank
you i suppose just on the categorical
points i think that's really important
i would love to say here sit here and
say you know categorically we will not
slip past that 15th of april date and we
are working towards that date and we
have no indication this time that
anything should slip past that
but we have been living in unprecedented
times and i don't want to blame corbyn
for anything because we've done that
enough and we talked about it to death
and i'm not there to do that
but there are things which have
disrupted the world we live in over the
last year two years
which have been very unfortunate and on
top of that um because there are
you know a number of organizations
across the land doing the same job in
terms of you know remediating tower
blocks that does put as we've reported
to scrutiny before a large pressure on
workforce a large pressure materials a
large pressure on the experts who advise
on that and what we've found is they've
been very stretched and there isn't
enough expertise out there to do this
type of works but we do not but what i
can say is we do not see anything at
this point which should delay us past
that date i've given but if an
unforeseen happens i'm not going to say
categorically if it doesn't happens but
it may but we do not see anything at
this point that should slip us past that
date in terms of the second i suppose
point in terms of
us not giving any sort of an enough
strong date i suppose
happy to come back and
are happy to give you more detail in
writing of course as always
um and apologies if you don't feel
that's enough and from our point of view
what we have done is today in the
opening i gave you some you know
detailed information of how number of
times we have corresponded with
customers
yes we do consult with customers about a
number of items as in the council we'll
consult with them about a number of
items and that's also very much
determined on what customers come and
talk to us about but what we can do is
quite easily share you what those
customers concerns have been for the
high-rise group what they've asked to
talk about in more detail and ask for
more information on and share that with
yourself to show the flavor of
information that's coming through
hi thanks for the update um
i may recall this incorrectly so
tell me if i'm wrong um was it right you
said you had to remove the insulation
when the when the cladding was off the
building
yeah i think i'll just bring on andy's
done all the detailed work so he's
probably a mix is the answer but i'll
give you the detail
there were isolated flats something he
did but installation was removed
from the facade of the building where
the cladding was it only affected the a
limited number because the cladding was
only on fifty percent of the block to
start with then only a small percent
about 15 percent were affected and we
probably had about three or four
customers who were sort of directly
affected by that and we dealt with each
case
sort of on its own basis in its own
merits so can i ask um how long they
were without insulation and how much
that affected their fuel bills i know
it's been difficult for a lot of people
this winter with fuel bills were you
able to offer any compensation for that
i've got the site i've got the specific
dates or the details around how long
each one but what i cancelled each
customer's complaint was closed down
satisfactory
um to their request and it was
compensation
customers thank you very much
[Music]
uh yeah could i just uh add a few things
um first of all with reference to your
communications from great manchester
fire and rescue service you said that
you've followed all of the advice you've
been given
um i've asked for this copy of this
advice the correspondence between
yourself and them uh because in january
2020 uh the trust stated that the reason
they hadn't completed in 2018 as they
had hoped was because they were advised
not to do remove the client by great
management fire and rescue service as
that would endanger people more exposing
the polyethylene underneath
um it also relates to the uh the matter
of the insulation being removed there
are two blocks that have had the
insulation removed for over two years
with scaffolding on that's a direct
contradiction to what was said at the
scrutiny committee meeting i would like
to know
if you were advised that it was okay to
remove the cladding and take it back to
brick as you so rightly said you wanted
to do in 2020.
um like say there's been two blocks
empress and princess court had it had
had the cladding off for over two years
of the scaffolding up
now
i appreciate the fact that you're saying
only 30 people complain but
are those the percentage of people that
actually live in these blocks how many
engage with the trust
because i would imagine it's not a high
percentage um with reference to the
high-rise living panel i'm actually on
the high-rise living panel and i have
been
for about a year just over a year um
and it's very
it's very different because there's only
myself and i think two of the people who
live in the affected blocks with the acm
cladding
so the issues
that we face
they are brought up but
i brought an incident where the the fire
assembly point was moved um
that wasn't action upon for months i
brought that up in the high-rise
climbing meeting and then i made a
complaint about it
um also
along with this um
i appreciate that you say that the works
are complete now all the blocks apart
from clifford but there were workmen at
the bottom of pickford court yesterday
completing the tarmacking which
you know grenfell was 2017
and to say for the last year two years
there have been issues with co-word and
supply and logistical i appreciate all
of that
but my issue is the
grenfell is 2017 the five year
anniversary is coming up in two months
and there's still scaffolding up on one
of the blocks
for me
what was said in january 2020
does not correspond to what has happened
and i want to know why the work didn't
start until 2019 whereas the trust
expressed their their great belief that
they wanted to do it all in 2018 but
they couldn't because of the advice they
were given
just to add to that i have questioned
the great manchester fire and rescue
service as well i've sent a free
information request which unfortunately
they're not able to provide because the
person is unavailable at the moment
i basically want to get to the bottom of
it i want to see the correspondence and
the advice that was given because it's
in direct contradiction to what's
actually happened and with regards to
compensation for residents it may only
affect 15 of the building but when
you're living in the building and you
see eight fire engines at the bottom of
the building like on the 20th of
february this year
it's a massive massive
anxiety cause for everybody there was
eight units there on the 20th the fire
exit the main entrance to pickford court
was not fully functional and it still
isn't
now i appreciate you maybe waiting for
parts waiting for a new door
the closer was faulty so that was
removed then it was put back on and the
closer would only open three feet i have
a push chair i could barely get through
thank god that that wasn't the case on
the 20th when there was a fire on the
10th floor and when i asked the fire
brigade the via commander on site along
with a lot of other residents who were
there looking up and feeling anxious
what was the issue oh well i don't know
not been up the worst thing for any of
these residents is not knowing the trust
has always said it wants to be
transparent it wants to be open it wants
to be honest i want that too and so does
every other person that lives in that
block
because it isn't just a case of for the
last year year and a half i had a
newborn baby in fact in my may my god
will kill me in may of 2020.
my building was the last to have the acm
platinum removed in december 2020 so for
the first six months of my daughter's
life she had to live in a building with
the acm cladding there was a fire in my
building the following july she was two
months old
that's why i'm here because i want
openness i want transparency i want
honesty i haven't seen it yet my
questions because the first question i
asked was what were you told by great
management fire and rescue service
and if that's what you were told why did
you go ahead and take the cladding off
and leave it off some buildings for over
two years
i don't i was lucky i only had the club
i only had scaffolding up for probably
six months
it wasn't a nice place to live
where you had a window you're
scaffolding some people have been living
there for years so for me to say only 30
people complain them complete complaints
have been closed that's not the issue
the issue is
why
almost five years old from grenfell as
they're still cladding waiting to be
replaced
i appreciate all of the problems that
you've mentioned
but none of that makes any difference
because it should have been done
years ago not months ago and in relation
to the communications and defined dates
the last meeting that you were sending
in october of last year
you said that it'll be done by december
22nd
we're now in march and it's still not
done the only consistent thing that's
ever happened is that every date you've
given has come and gone
that's the only consistent thing that's
happened
it's okay
the issue around the conflict
of information that we received in terms
of the
tht received in terms of the
um the
fire service
advice that was given around the removal
of the cladding because i think it is an
important
issue because
um
you know people have had to suffer
because of that
so so
are you able to give
categorical advice that
um
that you've followed precisely what the
fire service
advice was
in terms of that issue
yeah
again and
[Music]
excuse me again apologies i i don't
disagree with anything that you've said
and you know i think the sentiment you
you've shown tonight is so important and
it's such an important issue for all the
all the reasons you raise
um you know i think
we have tried to be fully honest and
open throughout this process to make
sure that we do share all the
information but i i still understand
that people living in that people
working there's a there's a complete
difference with that and we've got to
try and you know empathize with the
people who are living through that um in
terms of the fire service you know i can
say yes we have followed all their
advice but what a you know
unfortunately what we wouldn't have is a
perfect sort of email trail of letter
show because it's not how it works the
fire service meters on site and talk
through what they want to see and then
we will go away and deliver that and now
if they're not unhappy if they're
unhappy with what they were doing they
could serve enforcement noticers or
different types of note owners and say
you have to do this to remedy that
because we're unhappy with the actions
you've taken
we have we've had no
notices served on us in relation to
those blocks or the work they've been
doing i mean i think so i think can i
just
bring you back though in terms of
the direct question
that
there was advice given
as i understand
according to mr stevenson
that
the cladding
shouldn't be removed
or or should be removed should i say and
that that's the advice that you were
given is that is that correct
because that's
i think i think the the bridge i suppose
when we identified that we had the same
acm cladding at the time and again i
would need to go back
we would have been advised at that time
of what the best course of action is i'm
not sure why you'd need to go back
because we put that into the questions
so
you you know you you
reported back
you know but you haven't answered that
question and that's quite a simple
question well yeah yeah but what i'm
trying to explain sharon i do and i
don't understand the question is that
that advice you know we have had x
number of advice notes from the
government for that period and i'm sure
you know how many we've had but the next
number in that period of time there's
been
x number of conversations with the fire
service during that period of time
and you know that's either be on site or
that's been in meetings or that's been
through correspondence and what we can
say
is that as each of those advice notes
has come out and as each of those bits
of advice been provided by the fire
service we have followed what they've
asked us to do and we have worked in the
best interests of the customers so yes
we can say that um and we you know
we have looked back through thousands
we're aware of that
going back to each specific piece of
advice though is difficult because the
amount you've had and that has been
a changing position through the whole
last two three years because this has
been an area where the whole building
industry has been gaining more knowledge
as it goes on so it's not just a
straight line from a to z that this is
the way we've worked
that advice has grown and developed
based on the work that's happened on
other tower blocks in the country so but
we can say yes we have followed all the
advice we've had and that's been
something that's been very important to
us to protect our customers
[Music]
if i'm right mr stevenson's aquarius
we would advise to leave the cladding on
and i think in your in your question you
were saying
then you shouldn't have taken it off
without being ready to go straight away
with a replacement
these yeah these were my words these
words of the representative trust at the
scrutiny meeting in january 2020. um the
advice pretty much word for word was we
were told not to remove the cladding and
expose the polio ethylene underneath as
it would cause a great risk to residents
this is the reason why it hadn't been
done
to that point
even though they wanted to do it in 2018
my issue is
in 2019 the scaffolding went up the
cladding was starting to be removed now
i appreciate you saying you don't have
every correspondence that's fair enough
perhaps you could provide the
correspondence that informs the
residents of the changes because as a
resident at no point was i told that the
advice had changed from do not take it
off until you have a suitable
replacement immediately so it's okay to
take it off this was published in the
manchester evening news along with a
false statement about three towers being
completed incorrectly some people don't
have the internet some people aren't
aware of this for them that's the only
information they receive they didn't get
told by the truster of the fire services
now told us it's okay to do that
so my issue is if your advice changed
from what you said in 2020 why did you
not tell anybody because you've got
residents in these buildings who've had
the cladding off with scaffolding for
two years thinking am i more at risk no
it's not on that's my issue that's been
the issue since then
and i suppose the bit that we can answer
there is what we've been saying yes we
did follow all the advice and yes that
advice when it's there is to protect the
customer and make sure that you are
living in the safest block possible if
that communication hasn't gone up i
apologize we have done a number of
communications that period as i made
clear in the opening but the aim through
this is always to make sure that we
follow the advice out there to keep the
customers as safe as possible and that's
what that's what we have done i
recognize and you know agree that this
has taken a long time to do but still as
i drive around and people drive around
you will see blocks up with scaffolding
up where cladding's still being removed
from blocks across greater manchester
across the country and you know we have
worked within our ability within the
constraints we've had to get that
concluded as quickly as possible and as
i said in the opening the positive news
is
yes i accept some minor ground works are
happening around the blocks to just tidy
up fixed tarmac etc
but the majority of the blocks now four
of them
scaffolding has been replaced
one of them we've had a delay for the
reason said earlier and we're now
employing a temporary solution to get it
ready and then we'll apply the final
solution following that
counselor diagno
hi uh again you have to forgive me i'm
not an expert in any of these areas um
from listening to your replies it i i
understand that um you appear to have
received a lot of perhaps contrary
advice or advice coming slowly or
perhaps too much all at once for you to
follow that you know
the path
that you followed hasn't really been
clear in terms of advice you're not able
to sum it up and and i appreciate that
that might have been difficult i'm just
wondering um and this is perhaps more
about how you might approach similar
problems going forward rather than this
particular case but was there not an
opportunity to employ um an industry
standards expert to guide you through
this it seems um
that that might have avoided quite a lot
of these difficulties maybe that person
doesn't exist but you seem to have been
really more reactive than proactive in
terms of managing it so i just wonder um
thinking about how you might approach a
similar problem in the future how would
you do any anything differently now
could you have done anything differently
that you would do if you had your chance
again i think i think we'd always try to
learn from everything we do yes is the
easy answer to that
just pick up the individual points we
didn't employ individual
experts within that and you know
there aren't many across the country
trust me and you do you do but we have
managed to employ industry experts who
have led and advised on that
but again if you if you think this is a
relatively new issue that we weren't
aware of until
um you know those industry experts have
also been learning along the way and
discovering sort of what the best
solutions are so again you are right
it's not be not being a straight path we
have tried to i suppose work the best of
our ability worked to those experts that
we talked about to get this resolved but
um yeah i think you know we would try
and learn one of the things we had we
did do straight away within these tower
blocks which we felt was really
important and i think it has been a real
positive is we didn't just look at the
cladding though one of the key things we
did is we looked at compartmentalization
within the blocks we looked at fire
safety in terms of fire exit fire doors
etc and any other additional works that
needed doing we got on and resolved
whilst cladding works was going on as
well so that you've got a whole block
solution there and we do believe that's
made the block surf safer and and and
sorry i'm i don't know your cern i'm
well well we're sorry and as wolf
pointed out we have had fires in that
blocks since then and actually what
we've found is each of those have been
contained the fire doors the flats the
compartmentalization has done the job
it's supposed to have done and it's kept
residents safe so we are very confident
we're in the right place and we are very
confident in the work that's happened
but but yes course we'd always learn and
we'd always look at what we do to
improve next time
so could i just ask then are you using
that same level of concern and
addressing issues across all of your
housing stock now
yes we we've done so if you look across
in terms of complex buildings so
high-rise sheltered walk-up flats we've
done exactly the same piece of work in
terms of doing the fire risk assessments
within those blocks undertaking any
compartmentalization needed undertaking
any change to fire doors fire alarms
that's been employed across all our
complex buildings and then in case of
houses we do what we need to do in terms
of those but there's a lot less to do in
terms of fire safety because they're not
got that same complexity behind them in
terms of you know corridors in terms of
walkways in terms of cladding but we do
look at those as well okay thank you
very much
okay so picking up on just
some of the comments you made there
the one that strikes me as worrying
is that you were talking about fire
safety feedback from greater manchester
fire service some of it written some of
it verbal
um with with such
critical safety things where you
will be liable if something happened and
you were you relied on a verbal
communication i would say going forward
you you have to have if you have a
verbal communication an email after it
says we discussed this we agreed this
uh that trail i mean i i have offices
when they want to tell me bad news that
they do not want to get out they phone
me and they tell me verbally because
then it can't be
but in writing it really must be for
that for critical far safety um i'm
quite concerned that you're mentioning
some of it was just verbal um
you know come first since you want to
add i think
i suppose while i was trying to portray
is that the fire service will meet us on
site and we'll talk through the work
we're doing so the example there and
andy can actually do the detailed work
is we do a fire risk assessment on all
our blocks and that tells us that work
that needs to be done and what we would
need to do and that's done on a regular
basis to update because things change
and people you know going to blocks and
some of our contractors customers will
do something about which makes it change
and therefore those fire risk
assessments are done on a regular basis
to make sure that we're always on top of
what needs to be done
what was the point is the fire service
will then come out and check that work
we're doing in check we're sticking to
that fire risk assessment and if they're
comfortable with that then then they're
not necessarily going to put that in
writing but they'll be comfortable but
we would always have that paper trail
that says this is the fire risk
assessment these are the works we're
doing to address that this is the action
plan we've got to address the things we
haven't done yet so we have got an audit
trail for every single complex building
that takes us through every issue
to when it's been resolved but what i'm
trying to portray is that sometimes just
me sometimes meetings will happen on
site and talk through things
so anything you wanted to add you picked
up most of it but the only thing about
that is
the fire servers don't tell us what to
do
we tell them what we're proposing to
build and based on our findings from
either fire risk assessments or we're
acting on government advice to the
advice notes that were given
post-growing photos in every one of
those
various captions
arising from an f4a
their actions we act on them and then we
will share them with the fire service
um and get their agreement that they
agree with the approach we're taking
because that assurance
um
and we take that proactive approach to
all our buildings we're not waiting for
things to happen it's proactive and to
touch on furthermore what gray mentioned
earlier
the compartmentation for the fire safety
order
doesn't didn't apply then to in to
inside flats
you know pretty much straight after
ground fault
our teams went into every single flight
in every high-rise building to do all
the complementation works
whilst the clothing was going on so it
was it was a
varied approach and absolute approach to
fire safety it wasn't just about the
clogging
can i just add set up i mean i
appreciate what you're saying it wasn't
just about the cladding but if you live
in a building with that cladding and you
saw what happened at grenfell it is
about the client 15
is 15 too much
and if you're telling me the
fire service don't tell you what to do
you sell them
why did trafford house intro say that
the reason they hadn't done anything
until 2090 2020 because they wanted to
do it in 2018 why are they saying that
that was on the advice of great
manchester fire and rescue service i've
asked for this information of a freedom
information request and i'm just meeting
resistance on it so i'm referring them
to the information commissioner's office
it's not enough to say
we were told nobody told the residents
that information had changed that the
advice had changed you've got people who
don't know what's going on they've got
scaffolding there's no cladding on and
the last they knew was we were told not
to take it off because we didn't have a
suitable replacement to immediately
replace at no point did i receive any
communication or any resident i know
received communications to say that
advice had changed we're okay to now go
ahead and do it at the end of the day
it's okay meeting the rules and
regulations but the first people to come
first the residents because they're the
people who are living in these buildings
if you're saying you have
fire risk assessments from that period
i'd like to see
and i genuinely would like to see the
risk assessments from that period for
when the works commenced the empress and
princess court when the cladding was
taken off
and then the risk assessment by the fire
brigade once the planning was off
because that directly contravenes what
was said
at the scrutiny committee meeting and
what was published in the local
newspaper so a lot of people that's the
only information they get this is this
is my my the whole the whole reason i'm
here is to find out why what you did was
not what you said
and that has had a direct effect on me
my family a lot of other residents that
i know there and it isn't just about the
people who complain not a lot of people
engage i know that
but it's got to be open it's got to be
transparent and if you've got that
information
definitely make it public let's have it
because it needs to be cleared up
i need it clearly
should i do it yeah i i i i i suppose i
was going to say is that you know we
have
tried to be open and transparent through
the process i recognize and i said in my
opinion our information won't always be
perfect you know i'd never i i wish i
was perfect and got everything out right
first time i'm not committing to say
that we've done that but we have tried
to communicate with residents as
effectively as we possibly can for a
very changing difficult environment
where we recognize this huge concern um
you know we have shared the information
we've had we've attended scrutiny
committee on a number of number of
occasions now to address this point
these points and you know we are going
over some of the the same ground now but
i do believe that we you know as if
we've said to committee we have followed
that advice at each point of the way and
we have worked in the best interesting
with customers to keep them safe and
that's from a whole building approach
not just in relation to the cladding has
been said
i think i think in terms of the
communications
it seems to me from what
uh
mr stevenson's saying is that
on the cricket critical staging of the
work that's been done
it's not been announced like for
instance the scaffolding but it's going
to remain for another three months or
it's going to remain for another nine
months or whatever it's not been relayed
so all it is
you know the residents are stuck there
looking at it
not seeing any work being done
and
you know they get disillusioned really
in terms of
that that's what it seems like
no you know i'm not there so i i can't
say for definitely
you've not
clearly stated
that at those critical points that you
you have consulted and then going back
to the learning points has been
mentioned which i think is a good point
is that that is probably something we do
need to take well that is something we
do need to take on board look at those
key stages of communication
and when we've done that have we given
strong enough reasoning to our customers
so they understand why we're doing some
other time now
what we're on and we're past that point
now but um i do take that on board and
we can go away and look at how we you
know build that into our communications
and talk to our communications team to
make sure that's improved not just for
the tower box but obviously for all our
residents because you know there's
issues that we talk about all the time
across our 10 000 homes
and i think the fire assessments that
are given
to you
doesn't seem to be relayed
to the residents as well so
you know are you prepared to
you know
reveal that
my understanding was that the most
up-to-date
fras were
on our website but i i'll need to go
back and check yeah it's one thing but
we do yeah we do publish fire safety
information on our notice boards in our
blocks on our website um can we go back
and check what's on there and just make
sure that relevant information
information's on there
yeah
yeah
yeah
right so oh sorry sorry
counselor bill
yeah it's just a quick one on the
replacement cladding i realized
obviously it was
uh difficult to source at a time when
everybody was trying to do the same
thing but did you have any kind of
projections as to when you would receive
it you know there's a part of the
project planned so that that would have
been able to give people some
information and the time scales of being
able to do things
[Music]
so the communication we we give out is
based on
the the contractors program information
so they liaise with their supply chain
they get estimated or
confirmed all the beliefs are confirmed
delivery dates and from there they
calculate the resource to determine when
they're going to hit key stages
and that's when we will give an update
to customers yeah we received an update
this morning from our contractor and we
hadn't delivered letters this afternoon
um to the affected block
so
we were communicating based on the
contractors program
which at the time is is correct at the
time of of writing but obviously there's
a lot of moving parts you know there's
contractors to contract the supply chain
and then you're throwing breaks and
everything else so there were
complications across the way but
if we'd force if we'd for seeing it we
would we'd be able to communicate to our
customers so but we don't communicate
what we know to be factual at a time of
communicating
i hope that answers a question
what's the final point chair for me can
you undertake to provide us via alex in
a month so on the 16th of april an
update as to where this is up to
um and i don't mean two weeks after i
mean on the 16th of april and also i
think in future when
presenting a report to this committee
we would like to see a little bit more
detail than what you've given us
particularly we would like to see it
proofread because this is hard to read
frankly um
you know
we probably don't take us very seriously
but it would be nice if tht took members
seriously so i think in future can we
have that thank you
sorry sorry um i'm just gonna come in to
agree uh i i do take seriously i'm an
executive director of the trust and you
know i have come here tonight because i
do take the committee seriously the
trust takes you seriously apologies if
that hasn't come across
um you know i think throughout this
process we have been scrutin on a number
of occasions um but if if you feel
that's the case we'll go back and have a
look and see what else we can do
now could i just
ask about the sprinklers because
um
it is something
that i know
the fire service
highly recommends sprinklers
highly recommend sprinklers
and we've been asking in this committee
um
you know to to
see whether the
tht will make progress on this and the
answer that we've got here
is exactly the same answer that we got
three years ago quite frankly
because i remember it well
um
and it said
at that time that we will be considering
as part of our overall business plans
the outcome of which will become the
subject of future customer consultation
that's exactly the same wording
for three years ago
and
so
in the next three years are we going to
get the same
answer
it's probably a similar answer because
because
there's different measures you can you
can put into a building
to make it being as safe as possible
and to prevent the spread of fire and
smoke
sprinklers
are a good form of mitigation
but where buildings are being remediated
fully and the compartmentation of them
else is intact and as as it should be
then
sprinklers aren't necessarily required
but we've got provision within our
future investment plans
to install sprinklers if
our sort of fire safety consultants and
experts
advisors that's the best course of
mitigation for that block but there's
other mitigation measures you can take
such as upgrading fire alarms etc
but absolutely where we feel
and our experts feel that the absolute
best course of action to keep customers
safe is to install sprinklers then we
will of course install sprinklers
the experts are the fire
firefighter to the
primary authority and agreement chair
with them and
we run every sort of solution we come up
with for each building past them and we
take their advice seriously and if and
as i said if the fire service advises to
fit a spring cleaning a building then we
will take it very seriously
i'll probably go to another
another meeting in the future
for your future plans
um i don't think it is is there anything
else that anybody wants to raise
we've been on this for a while now no
i would only say that um i really do
think the director of tht ought to be
here to hear um the history that's been
relayed to us to hear our concerns to
the residents concerned and to take that
responsibility directly i think it's
time well they had a chance didn't they
yes i do yes i appreciate they had a
chance but i'm just saying for the
record i think they ought to be here
okay
yeah counselor carter
thanks chair just for clarity because as
you said that's been quite a long
conversation are there any specific
action points
resulting from that
well
yeah
yeah i think
what we were asking for was a further
update
for clarity on some of the issues
yeah
yeah
so
are those
absolutely specific issues known and
understood by the people who are going
to answer in the questions
in the minutes will it specify this is
what we want to know by this date
well we still would like to know whether
we actually
will
will
get it is
um a response in terms of
the advice that was given by the fire
service
now
what's being said is that that advice
could have been given
verbally and not in writing so
but i would have thought that
you know a conversation with a fire
service
um by tht could
could clear that one up
and to report back to us
uh with what they and
possibly
that update after a month and possibly
if it's not if that's not final a
monthly update on where the work's up to
on clifford call i think again modern
comfortable response on the 16th has
been requested that's fully understood
in terms of the advice what we could
provide is i think there's been 20 25
advice notes provided by the government
at the time through this process we're
more than happy to share those advice
notes with yourself so you can see the
advice that's been provided along the
way
well we'll see what that is yeah
okay then
well
can i thank you for coming along
um
it is appreciated that you've come
before the committee
i think
i know that it has been a difficult
period and i think we all kind of
recognize that
um but grenfell was
a massive
massive
you know
thing that um
it's a lot to get over
quite frankly for for residents and i
know that you know as as officers um
and
i think there are
huge
amounts of lessons that everybody can
learn in relation
to
to what's what's happened but we we
would still like to
follow this and
you know
um
come back to it and you know have with
us specific things again tonight
um
but i also
like to thank you know you as officers
for coming along but i'd particularly
like to thank mr stevenson for coming
along because it is
very helpful for someone who
has been in the situation
uh within the
high-rise flats and
and the difficulties in having to go
through what you've had to go through
and i think you've done it
you know you you've raised the issues in
a calm way
um
and
in a powerful way
i think you know the members appreciate
that
um i just like to say thanks for have
thanks for having me it's it's
it's good to know that this facility is
available uh not not just because of
this but for other things as well and i
do appreciate the fact that the trusted
turned up tonight yeah
it's helped enable me to look at the
questions
so
you could stay for the rest of the
meeting
if you wish to
but
we will excuse you if you don't
yeah yeah no thank you
[Music]
right
so
uh item six is
contract procedure rules
so that's me presenting sure
yeah sorry yeah
um
[Music]
sorry rob can you just use your
microphone please
it'll just go red if it does i'll just
try the one next year if that one's not
working
thank you
can you hear me okay yes
right sorry did you hear me introduce
myself okay
i'll start again thank you sorry
um right for so for those of you who
don't know i am um my name is rob
smithson i'm a contract and procurement
solicitor here at traffic council um the
item i'm presenting tonight is a
proposed update to the contract
procedure rules
and in your papers you've got a report
um the draft
new contract procedure rules and a table
of amendments um
quite extensive amount of documents to
go through so i'm going to use this
slideshow to kind of go through the main
points
of the update to the contract procedure
rules
um
so the contract procedure rules are a
part of
um the council's constitution um
basically
as it says on the tent that they're
there to provide the procedures and
rules for dealing with the contracts
awarded by the council so they're
reflected in the standing orders in
terms of the decision-making process i
when it's members when it's officers
when it's committees um
they also reflect the relevant let's
legislation uh key part this is the
public contract regulations
which dictates what
must be done for
um
contracts above a certain value
um
the cprs
kind of focus more on below the
threshold value so basically you know
what our rules for when the legislation
doesn't tell us what to do
and provide framework for robust
governance
now
um trafford is actually um
in partnership in the host authority for
the star organization which is made up
of four different um
councils
stockport trafford rochester and team
side and as such all cprs are harmonized
with
the other three authorities i it's
reflected in their constitutions as well
as our own
uh that's to make star able to function
um as a procurement organization for all
four
um
so moving on to the next slide
so the reason for review um
firstly to ensure that the cprs are
future proof um
some of the operational procedural
aspects and provisions
rather than remaining within the uh cprs
and i part of the constitution are going
to transfer to the star procurement
handbook
this this is mainly about what the
procurement officers are supposed to do
when they're dealing with certain
contracts
and
third reason for review uh is to
incorporate changes to legislation and
we had the um brexit reform referendum
in 2016 and since 2020 we
have been
moving um
away from the eu legislation and
thirdly to make make sure we're
maintaining the harmonized rules and to
allow effective and consistent
procurement and contracting processes
across
the store
partners
so the review process um it has been
ongoing for some times there was delays
well
pandemic um
[Music]
trafford out before authorities took the
lead in 2021 to drive this forward and
we consulted with and the legal teams
across all four star authorities
and it reflects feedback from
star organization itself star board
members and the continuous improvement
group there's been a series of drafts
and reviews of this document
and we've now reached agreed position
across the four legal teams
um of each star authority to take
forward uh into the each of the four
constitutional
processes um
now key amendments uh one of these is
the quote process and
it was proposed that
so
currently um if
the contract is worth under 5000 pounds
and
it only requires one quote to be
obtained it's been uh requested that
this be increased to
99999 pounds
and risk analysis was carried out by
star
and it was worked out it would affect
about
40 contracts per canal council per annum
and with the effect on overall spend one
million one hundred and thirty nine
thousand one hundred ninety four
which is
north point north north
north
nine percent i hope i've got the right
number of notes there based on uh 1 200
million estimated
spending total
um
so it's felt you know it wasn't huge
risk to do this um
further key amendment um modifications
to contracts so these are existing
contracts and
so the ground within the cprs currently
reflects the public contract
requirements um which set a high
standard for
modifying a contract already in
existence
and
so it was limiting financial and scope
caps and
it was felt that additional ground was
needed to enable a modification where
there was exceptional circumstances
as agreed by the sro for ligo so i mean
for example so allows flexibility in
exceptional circumstances
a great example of this has been what
we've been living through the last two
years in terms of covering what was
needed and
getting done things done quicker than
the normal procurement process is
allowed
um
other key men again talking about
modifications so this again this is
amending a contract or unix in existence
and in terms of contract term extensions
it was felt there was a need for a
sensible approach
but we need to simplify the process
where the modification is in respect of
an extension to the term which was
provided for the initial procurement
documents in the contract so if it was
already there when the contract was
tenders and this is about making the
process simpler rather than going
through a bureaucratic process it was
felt that you know if we in these
circumstances if we had the sro for the
relevant service and the direction of
procurement or agreement it would be
allowed built for us to approve the
modification
and
due diligence checks would remain in
place
but it was to ensure that contracts
within bill extension periods can be
extended without any unnecessary delay
further key amendments this was about
operational process detail and i touched
on this earlier but it's about basically
taking out
more procedural elements out of the cprs
and into the star handbook and which
would still provide detailed guidance
but allowed to be updated periodically
to reflect operational changes and
improvements
and um legal still have oversight of the
redraft
and but importantly the business of the
rule framework would remain in place
now this slide uh this is more to kind
of demonstrate here the um
constitutional process that
so this this is for trafford
but times this by four bear in mind
there's four um councils involved in
star
and just give you a flavor of basically
the approval journey
um for the cprs
and so yep this scrutiny it went to the
star joint committee this morning and i
think it was standards on monday
um
so after here and the next stage would
possibly be executive in castle and like
i said
this is happening in rochdale
and team size and stockport depending on
what their constitutional requirements
are
so um yep
any questions
thanks for for that um i'm pleased you
said that we're not going to go through
all of the report because it's a massive
report and i think you know as a
recommendations
says
um we're asked to uh note the content
of the report
um
and
uh it has gone through a process it's
been to standards and
um the constitution working group
and
other
bodies and
within the council
and on monday it'll go to the executive
and then on the wednesday to full
council so really we we're asked
to um you know to note this report
yeah are we okay with that
yeah
all right thank you
yeah
yeah just a comment uh just to say that
i'm always wary of reports that say
making things foolproof because nothing
more certain in nature than
change
so
just something i wanted to make
yeah well
you're right about that
um
right okay so we we're agreed with that
and thank thank you very much and thank
you for coming tonight and explaining
that
i would say the same thing you're you
know you could stay if you wish but
i've never had anybody who's ever stayed
that's your
[Laughter]
appeals yeah
right
the next item is seven and it's a
carrington relief road
so
aiden are you going to introduce the
report
yes thank you chair um good evening
councillors for those who don't know me
i'm adrian fisher i'm director of growth
and regulatory services um and this
report follows
the presentation that was made to this
committee in january and
the committee after that requested some
further information in particular
a report rather than a presentation
so um i know you will have had this but
if i may i would just like to pick out a
few points um by way of emphasis and
then obviously very happy to take any
questions uh subsequent to that
um so in terms of background uh the
report does sort of perhaps give a
little bit more detail as to sort of how
how have we arrived at the point where
we are um because i know there's quite a
lot of discussion on this in in in
january um
and
essentially as you can see it really it
stems from a series of of decisions that
the council has made over a a number of
years but but most notably it really
stems from
the decision to redevelop
the former shell refinery so the shell
refinery petrochemical refinery closed
in in in the 2000s
and with that came the opportunity for
additional development alongside it
might have some other sites as well in
in in the carrington area and that was
wrapped up into the 2012 core strategy
and it is that in the first instance
that necessitates uh transport
improvement in the area
and
you'll note that
a number of uh sites
that are proposed for development or
indeed and some that have planning
permission
have
significant constraints really because
of the current highway network is simply
not of sufficient capacity to
accommodate that development and and in
other words that in the granting of
permission we're exceeding um the the
the the necessary thresholds um and that
it would result in a severe impact so so
you have a the sort of background of
development that was uh proposed back in
uh well 10 years ago really
and that has been steadily coming to
fruition over the previous years that of
course compounds a situation where uh
even probably without that the geography
of the area is is is not ideal in that
you have the um partington very much out
on on on a on a limb as it were very
much dependent on on a single road for
for much of the the traffic
so on top of that we then also have the
decision uh
uh attendant with the places for
everyone planned so that was approved by
the council
uh uh last
year
it's been submitted now to the
government um uh full formal examination
but as far as this authority is
concerned um that's now a formal policy
of the authority
and and what that does is
um
add to uh the scale of development in in
this area and the um
uh that plan uh
not quite sort of took it as read that
the uh road um
would be developed but at least assume
that this was programmed and therefore
any additional infrastructure would be
over and on top of that
and
as i think is explained last time when
we talk about
the road we need always to be careful
that we're doing so in
in the context that this is one of a
series of transport improvements that
are necessary so it's not just about the
road transport
and particularly
not just about uh individual car
transport but it's about a range of
infrastructure improvements
so that's the sort of broad background
and then that distills down into
particular decisions that have been made
as regards to
the road itself
and that was subject to as members will
be aware of a an executive report and
decision last september which considered
various route options and the the option
that was favored was what's known as
route f which
essentially runs through uh the middle
of the uh former petrochemical site and
then there were
in effect two choices one was to follow
more or less existing road alignment um
and the second was to uh pursue a new
line um across what are currently open
fields and it was that latter line
that was chosen
so that's sort of
essentially how we've arrived at
where we are
so following that executive decision um
there is now a
program of work which is is underway
um and that's really working this up in
much much more detail
um
and
so the timeline as you can see there in
in 2.3
is is in two parts it's geared
uh towards um
work that will lead to the submission of
a planning application
um
and then
there will be further actions that would
flow
subsequent to that
if that planning application is is
approved um so essentially where we are
is that we are in the middle of um well
not really the middle actually we're in
the early stages
of
some
much more detailed design work
and environmental
assessment alongside that
so in terms of um uh the budget
situation because again i think that was
um something that members were
interested in last time you'll see there
section three some of the the detail of
uh
the funding that is is currently
available uh towards uh the road um
and um
uh that is from a a range of sources but
i think we need to be clear that the
um the funding currently identified
whilst uh will be sufficient for the for
the sort of agreed phase of work of what
the executive has agreed
um is in no ways going to be sufficient
to cover the full cost of the road
and
one of the tasks that the design team
are doing at the moment is really trying
to get the best possible estimate
of of costings bearing in mind that
pretty much everything in terms of
prices is is moving quite um
significantly at the moment
um
i put there in 3.7 just a sense of
the cost of infrastructure improvements
overall um unfortunately
whatever you choose to do is is
invariably extremely expensive um and
you can get a sense of
of of some of the costs of
relatively recently completed schemes or
ones that are nearing completion
um
often covering relatively small
distances but with some fairly
significant um sums of of money involved
so what would happen or what would need
to happen essentially
uh
if planning the planning application is
successful is the council will clearly
need to make a decision then as to the
formal progression of the scheme and
that would have to be attended by a a
full finance strategy and a lot more
information as well
at that point
um
section four just highlight some of the
um issues around carbon because
again i think that was a topic that was
considered um last time
and certainly i think there has been
some concern over the
uh possibility of impact on pete uh and
certainly pete has been identified in
one of the ball holes uh of of the road
but but only one so far but but that is
sufficient to mean that we must do more
work on this
and and essentially one of the
the the issues that we will have with
this uh this road and indeed any
infrastructure project is that you you
never have or very rarely have a perfect
solution
so um
clearly that
overall there might be benefits in terms
of uh the the root f
but one of the dis benefits very clearly
is that it crosses agricultural land we
need to be absolutely clear about that
um and so that um that that is a you
know is a dis benefit and that will have
to be accommodated um in terms of the
detailed design
but more widely i suppose in terms of
transport strategy um
you know were we to scroll back
100 years or so this area would have
been relatively well served by water and
by railways and indeed light railway um
and sadly over the past many decades all
of that infrastructure has been
dismantled and in place we now have a
transport system that is very heavily
reliant on on roads and and
realistically you know the idea that
overnight that we would dispense with
road infrastructure
is you know
as a nation we we can't do that but what
we can do is similarly over time
kind of rebuild some of the other
infrastructure and also make the road
transport um significantly more carbon
friendly um such that you know over time
most of the vehicles um won't have uh
internal combustion engines they'll be
powered by other other sources um and
certainly um
the way that a road
can be designed now
can be designed in a much better way
than it would have been even you know
probably 20 years ago
and if you consider some of the areas
around here particularly like white city
it's a very unpleasant place to walk or
cycle
modern roads aren't necessarily like
that and certainly can include
measures like um you know bus priority
and
proper bus facilities
so in terms of um then the you know what
will need to happen next as i say um
there is a lot of very detailed
technical assessment to be carried out
um
some of that will involve
some transport modelling
and
a lot of investigation of as to
both
environment drainage ground conditions
and such like
uh there will be a need for formal
public consultation uh uh a part of
ahead of the the the planning process so
obviously the planning application will
have its consultation but ahead of that
there'll be a need for consultation and
there will also be a need to engage with
various groups as well so it may be you
know the
cycling groups or horse riding groups or
you know
other residents and such like um so
there will need to be that kind of
informal engagement to help guide uh the
design
uh and then as i say ultimately that
will lead to a planning application and
that might in turn necessitate a
business case
so in terms of of the involvement of the
committee um and i think that was one of
the key questions from last time
and really of course share this is for
committee members to to to think about
but but some suggestions if i may um
would would be really perhaps in terms
of
um
uh you know those
periods of engagement either informal or
indeed the way that the the kind of
pre-application consultation is carried
out
clearly there's a
an opportunity
to shape and guide that if if members
are so minded
um and then equally of course further
down the line as we head towards the
executive then equally um there'll be
opportunities around that i suppose to
finance um and uh the formulation of the
business case
um and then um perhaps another area and
i'm sorry it's not in the report but
it's it's it's come out in a more recent
meeting but um another suggestion if i
may is
one of the things that will need to
happen
uh or or perhaps is proposed to happen
is uh the remodeling of the existing
a6144 so that will still need to be used
by people who live along it and by a
certain amount of traffic
but equally
uh
the project has always assumed that
to some extent that would be you know
that would be calmed down it would
become um a much more sort of slower
speed route generally than certainly it
is at the moment and and if you know it
you'll know that it is absolutely not a
a pleasant road to be alongside
or indeed to use for
for many people so the
what happens and the considerations that
apply to that again might be an area for
the committee to explore
so
just some suggestions chair and
obviously very happy to take any
questions thank you
thank you
for that i think that that's helpful
um
as members will know we did
agree at the last meeting when we
discussed this matter uh that we would
look at the next steps in delivering of
the relief road
and
um
and i think set out particularly
in five and
six and
two as well
um
you know
it's going to be a long project
i think consultation and
environmental
assessments uh an impact um
you know it's something else i think
would be very interested in
um looking more closely at
um so
yeah rob well thanks chair um i'm d mob
happy now so i'm just going to say
whatever i fancy um
i always did yeah that's true um chair i
have to say i mean my concerns about
this were rehearsed at the last meeting
i i am still concerned and whilst the
report does
you know demonstrate quite a contrast to
the last one we're presented with you
know it is well written and i don't
agree with some aspects of it but it is
you know thorough and you have been so
as well adrian but
the
decision that was made on the route
i was concerned that that was made on
the basis of
a consultation that could not have been
because of the circumstances at the time
as full a discussion as
was required
i would like to see that addressed
further as the process goes on
particularly with residents
and
i think the exec member is going to have
to get used to being a bit less
combative um on the whole subject
because i was disappointed with his
attitude at the last meeting which is
not you know you can't answer that
adrian but which is why it was quite
refreshing to hear it you know it from
coming from you
um
i think
this this has got a long way to go you
know i'm not going to see it through but
there's going to have to be discussions
with residents um on this subject
because that route that has been chosen
is by no means
um uncontroversial
so i think that just needs to be born in
mind and reflected in a future report if
i may say so adrian thank you
um so you know i have my doubts about
how um as i discussed before how this is
going to kind of comply with a 2040
greater match transport strategy
with the targets of 50 of all
journalists being made by walking
cycling public transport and zero net
growth in motor vehicle traffic between
2017 and 2040. but the questions i
wanted to ask today about the funding
i know there's a big funding gap and
i just wondered how secure the funding
that's suggested in the report from
private developments
and the bid for the city region's
sustainable transport fund how secure
those might be
um especially with the city region
sustainable transport fund because it
does seem to have an objective for
decarbonising transport
especially promoting a mobile shift from
cars to public transport walking and
cycling
so i mean what will happen if that
funding gap is not met
and what kind of financial risks might
there be in this road
the other question that's kind of linked
to that was i know that there was
figures given there in 3.7 to say that
these other projects cost
a significant amount as well
but it was a bit hard to i was trying to
think about you know the metrolink
figure there is possibly put there as a
comparative figure but i can't
i don't know how much
this this the estimated estimated cost
of this project is yet and how that
actually works if you compare for
example building a metro link to
to building a road what would be the
difference in that price and obviously
it's completely an utterly different
kind of project because the metro link
would potentially bring in funding so
those are my questions we've got some
more
uh yeah yeah thank you chair and yes and
and thank you for the question so in
terms of the the funding probably um
uh the the absolute the thing that is
probably most secure the the planning
obligation um
monies that have been received because
you know that's that's money that's
secured um already um the other ones are
[Music]
mostly conditional
so subject to funding agreements with
with conditions um holmes england have
though given um
uh
two million pounds of advanced uh money
with lesser conditions
um in effect recognizing that you know
you've got to kind of keep things moving
and therefore
um
it it with with less onerous conditions
um
in terms of the uh the costings at 3.7
you're absolutely right of course
metrolink is a very different animal but
i suppose
people would say well what why why why
why build a road and why not also build
uh or extend the metrolink and and in an
ideal world and i think i explained last
time you know there is the the green
corridor the former railway line which
is still owned by network rail um uh
which would be you know fantastic to to
reinstate um
but but you know there will be
significant price tags to to either
heavy or light rail probably the best
comparator might be the point and relief
road which is nearing completion it's
under construction at the moment um i
understand the cost so that's about 53
million for a three kilometer road so
that just gives a sense i suppose what
i'm trying to convey is you know
relatively small infrastructure
improvements can still be
pretty expensive um and so uh when we're
talking about 17 million pounds which
obviously is a lot of money um that's
not going to be enough and the last
published estimate
uh for this project was 34 million but
what i all i can safely say is it will
be more than that and probably quite a
lot more than that so we're hoping to
work through those figures as soon as we
can
um
chair if i may uh counselor chilton i
think made some comments and i just
wanted to
re uh i suppose say that i do recognize
that
you know we we
we would have ideally and initially
wanted to do a lot more with residents
and so i do absolutely take on board
the comments that council chilton made
about trying to if you like repair that
and do do more because i think
pre-covered we set out with um to do a
number of things we weren't able to do
them um and um you know
we were trying our best to
get things on a better footing for the
future
thank you
thanks chair and thanks for the report
um i just wanted to ask about the s106
money in the at the moment it stands at
2.8 million but i take it the projected
money that we're hoping to get from the
s106 is around about eight million um
and
that will come from much of the new
development in carrington
where you would hope really that much of
that s106 money would go to ecological
mitigation but i take it that won't be
the case it will be go be funneling into
this road
i'd also just wanted to quickly ask that
on this relief road especially on the
shell site is a much of the
approved planning applications along
there for haulage firms
so
when we're trying to meet our carbon
targets we should be moving away from
haulage on roads but is it the case that
haulage along there will be expanding
and that's why we need more capacity
when really we should be trying to move
haulage to rail really
so there are two main questions thanks
uh yes so if i made um only 106 uh
you're obviously right that there will
uh hopefully be more of that to come um
and and but that's not necessarily at
the expense of
uh ecological mitigation and of course
one of the costs of the road which would
apply whichever route that you follow um
part of the cost of that is is is the
mitigation that is necessary so i think
whichever route we'd have chosen
that it would have required
environmental mitigation and that's part
of the cost um
but the the funding that will come from
um
the planning obligations
is is not um for the most part anyway in
place of other contributions it's simply
a recognition that in order to have
satisfactory access for the development
they um
there needs to be
transport mitigation and and that will
be and some of that at least will be in
the form of contributions for this
project
as far as um
new development obviously there is well
first i suppose there is some existing
development which we can't do anything
about
in terms of new developments then that
is a matter
uh really for obviously for applying the
council's planning policy through the
planning committee
at the moment we we could not turn down
a planning application for say you know
a warehouse just because it was road
based
and and it really goes back to my my
point that uh you know and it is very
frustrating in terms of the challenges
we have now because if you look at a map
of um this area you'll have seen it was
full of railway lines you know they had
um you know
little tramways um through to the ship
canal at various points um
you know they had networks at a little
bit like trafford park up the road which
had a rail network built into it
over time of course all those things
have fallen away so so we're now having
to deal with the situation as it stands
and certainly we couldn't refuse
a a planning application on that basis
but you know over time hopefully these
things will move national policy will
move and so that will enable us to
similarly adjust as well
thank you
thank you chair
um
thank you for coming back to us with
this um way folds how we can be engaged
more
um
with the process i really appreciate
that
and
the
formal consultation that's going to
start october to december
i would really like to have a briefing
um prior to that to look at the
consultation
process and how how it's going to work
and how the engagement is
going to look like
um i would really like a briefing
beforehand but any with enough time that
if we've got ideas to change or have
some
input into it that we would have enough
time to do that is that possible
uh chair well uh uh yes i would hope so
if the committee is so minded so um we
have um as part of the team
uh
that is it's all coming through as part
of the amy contract but that's the team
of specialists but there is a a
dedicated officer there uh who will look
at community engagement so that's their
essentially their their um
their role um
uh i was just trying to think when the
next you know the pattern of meetings
but i imagine perhaps by the summer
we'll have have maybe a draft plan of
engagement and that might be a suitable
time
you know for members to comment on it so
um so be very happy to do that
and i think i think it's really
important that we do
have that um
because obviously
the concerns
with regard to the route itself
um
you know means that we should at least
make sure that um
we we do do a thorough consultation
on the next stages um
and
so if something can be brought to us
an outlying plan
then hopefully we can
influence that
before it actually goes out to the
public
yeah
louise
yeah
thanks adrian um i just wondered um last
time you were here i don't recall
whether it was yourself or or councillor
right um
questioned the validity of non-residents
commenting
on on the current and relief road and i
just wanted to run by you
my understanding is that everybody has
um a valid
comment to make about this project
whether they live that are directly
affected by or they live locally or
they've got
issues and live nationally so i just
wanted to to ask will the consultation
take
account of everybody's contribution
and will everybody be engaged and i'm
not suggesting that you know it's a
national consultation but that the
comments received from people who don't
live within the area are not negated is
that going to be the case
yes i i would certainly expect that to
be the case i mean i suppose you might
say if there was somebody from cornwall
making a comment
uh as indeed does sometimes happen um
uh that you might give that rather less
weight but i think
something we have to recognize is that
this area will be used by people who
don't necessarily live in carrington but
may live within
you know perhaps five miles or i don't
know within a relatively short traveling
distance and so at first glance it might
be you might feel why are they affected
but it may be that you know that this is
the area where you know they they they
come and you know walk their dog or or
whatever else they might do or go for a
cycle ride so there will be all sorts of
people who who will be affected and
therefore i think for that very reason
um unless they are very obviously
perhaps
very far away um
their their views are still going to be
important yeah i mean not just people
who are personally affected i would just
say that you know a lot of people have
an interest a broad interest in
environmental issues and this does touch
on environmental issues and i think as a
council we have some responsibility to
consider and reflect it in our plans
their opinions such as we think
appropriate so it's just to make that
point really thankful i think i
think in making the point
i i
i think we've agreed really uh that we
are going to
have sort of pre-consultation around
um
you know a pre-discussion from scrutiny
with regard to the consultation that's
that will come along and i think all
those points
if it's not addressed in the draft we
can address it and i think they're there
you know and similar with uh other
things as well
julian first and then
i have
probably two points and a question so
the
and forgive me for this but i mean i
used to hear stories of
of nuclear power plants being built
where the foundations didn't weren't
reinforced and when that was pointed out
they reinforced doubly the rest of the
structure
having a in-depth consultation
after we've chosen an option
when the consultation
wasn't sufficient possibly on the option
is i would say similar to that
and that worries me that
to consult after the fact
so
firstly i went away and i read the 2012
course strategy
it mentions the road there at an
estimated cost of 3 million pounds now
even with inflation are we really
talking about the same road that we're
going to be spending tens of millions of
pounds on this road
multiples of that and it also in that
2012 core strategy it relies it talks
heavily about rail and the bridge so
it's uh to rely on that strategy for the
futures
without looking at the other two major
aspects of it is unfortunate but the one
that got me i noticed i went to look at
gmsf predating places for everyone i
looked at the area and there is a road
and it follows exactly the track of
um
the current proposal uh i believe that's
f
um
and i've got to thinking how do we how
are we
i'd like to answer how are we making
sure that we meet the gunning criteria
grounding principles
when
a design was already laid out in that
place
the consultation never never talked
about root options
um
how is it that we've we we're going to
satisfy ourselves we've met those
criteria when
pre predating that an option was already
drawn and in the consultation the
criteria of root options wasn't
mentioned
um
okay chair if i may i suppose a couple
of points in there um i suppose going
back to the
2012 core strategy um
really i can't account for why it would
say three million pounds i think that
was a
extremely optimistic um uh
uh figure um even in 2012
um and and certainly you you would have
you know
certainly the cost of construction has
risen disproportionately though i think
it's fair to say but uh three million
would have been very very good value
shall i say
um
in terms of the other uh
aspects of of that um
i mean we mustn't lose sight of those
because whilst all the the effort is you
know this report is about the road but
but the the road is one of the the
package of measures we also have things
like greenway the former railway line
um i think the the design of this road
will have evolved or thinking about
roads
has evolved since 2012 because um you
know it will include
much more um
much better facilities rather for
cyclists and certainly would have been
the case um historically so there is a
you know some of those other aspects
have moved on i know the um
core strategy also talked about a bridge
over the ship canal um which again i
think in the long term would be you know
probably very potentially quite helpful
linking this area to port salford but if
you consider the the cost and the of a
bridge and the difficulties for example
that we've experienced say with the
wiggis bridge at uh by the trafford
center um then that is not a
straightforward undertaking either so
you know
a few things with that in terms of the
gunning principles and the consultation
engagement i think all i can say is that
there was a sort of genuine
choice i mean you're quite right that
the
sort of broadly the the the desire line
of the road
has been somewhere near root f for some
time i think that's fair
but
the
uh
the choice really was a genuine and i
think personally i i expected the root
on the existing alignment
to perform rather better because um
you know it would involve less land take
you would have perhaps less you know
construction and various other other
issues but
taking the range of factors and also
taking into account the effectiveness of
the road because no point in building
something if it can't actually be made
to work the junctions don't actually
work and aren't effective and unsafe and
so on
so it was all i can say it was a genuine
choice i know people will feel that
perhaps the engagement wasn't sufficient
but it did go
very very far and wide i mean physically
the postcards went to um a very large
number of um
of
properties in a way which you know isn't
often done for consultations where we
rely on online things and so on so
i think you know
people have different views about that
but um i think all i can reiterate is
that it was a genuine choice that was
before the executive and certainly
wasn't a done deal from my point of view
and i was personally a little bit
surprised that perhaps it came out the
way it did in terms of um you know some
of the engineering and transport advice
thank you
thanks chair um
just reflecting on this agenda items
asking
that this committee considers how best
to be involved
um so just um thinking about that and
some of the comments uh made so far i
think uh the idea of us having a
contribution to the consultation before
it's at design stage before it's um
implemented to be reassuring i think to
a number of members if that can't be
fitted and within the
programme of uh scrutiny committee
meetings perhaps that could be done as a
subcommittee um
and the
vice chairs comments at the start about
there's a number of contentious issues
just thinking about how
members can more effectively scrutinize
if so you'll be aware of what the
contentious issues are because you live
and breathe them every day more than
some of us who look at it less
frequently so if in future reports those
con contentious issues could be spelled
out with what the pros cons
recommendations are with explanations of
how those recommendations came
um despite the fact that it was
contentious i think that would be
helpful and as part of the overall
package um if there is some
measure and target put on what
scale of disruption
um will residents and road users in the
area have to put up with for how long
and how can that be
minimized and mitigated and they'll be
really really helpful because by the
sound of this project
when it's decided it will take quite a
long time to implement
um and a final thought if we're looking
for further further ideas if we have
this relief road then how do we stop
heavy slow large vehicles continuing to
use the existing road even though
a road designed for their use might have
been put in place
thank you
i'll happily take take on board those
and and hopefully that that's and really
guided by um the committee as to when
when we come back on this um and i think
also the just on the latter point um
obviously the the kind of arrangements
the existing road uh i did suggest that
might be an area for the committee to
look at so so you know we'd be glad to
you know um
so thank you
yeah
and this is a kind of request
information really i mean i think um
you mentioned it mentions that the new
active travel infrastructure on the
route will encourage residents to make
healthy choices in life so it's kind of
wondering how that's going to work in
principle because i think it's more
about enabling than encouraging
personally um and i understand that part
of this is to offset the
carbon costs um so i understand in four
point six he says is one one million
pounds gonna be allocated to this i just
would appreciate some maybe some more
detail on
on how this active travel infrastructure
is gonna work on this road
the other thing was about on the
timeline it doesn't mention about the
environmental impact statement and when
that happens and
also the investigation work on the p and
we know when will they take place and
what kind of potential impact might
these have on the construction of the
road and the financial risks
attached to that would be good to have
some more information in the next report
maybe
can i just
say in
in terms of two two three in the summer
the ongoing design work i mean it's part
of that isn't it design of the
the the relief road so we should be able
to influence it um
through this process
yeah
influence what goes into the design
package
the design of the road that's what
you're talking about really in terms of
i don't know what i mean by influencing
it i'm just asking when these things are
going to take place
but it's taking place in summer in the
summer take place in the summer i
actually mentioned the timeline yeah and
certainly um
cancer that would be
part of all that information would would
accompany the planning application so
some of that will be only complete when
that application is submitted if you say
to me
okay then how
thank you
adrian last time you're here i i asked
about um
[Music]
who was going to use the units and how
how and what scoping you'd done in terms
of businesses that might want to move
into them
and i think what you suggested was at
the time was that especially with
covert had demonstrated for example a
need for warehousing provision etc i
just wondered um
i know that the clean air
proposals are on hold at the moment but
had they come in had they come about as
planned originally whether you think
that would have affected um how
people might have wanted to commit to
using those units do you think that have
been you know especially talking about
the amount of haulage for example that
might be coming out of there whether or
not you thought that those clean air
plans would make it less of a good
business proposal
and i know this is all conjecture but i
mean the clean air other clean air plans
will come back in some form um so are
they being taken into account will they
stop people wanting to use those units
you know are we going to end up with a
white elephant big question i'm sure
you're going to assume that we're going
to do nothing of the sort
yeah
yes um so
clean air plan has been put back but it
but it hasn't gone away so we have a
date of 20 to 26 rather than
2024 um and certainly um
we can't prejudge what might be
in the revised plan come july but i
think
most
um
it it's quite likely that heavy goods
vehicles would be included because in in
the various categories of clean air zone
you kind of
go up a list as it were and hdv's and
nearly always in there if you see to me
so um quite quite likely still to
feature but we don't know um
um but i suppose the answer to this is
is that
um horlish companies and logistic
companies are really working incredibly
hard to
reduce their reliance on you know
certainly um old vehicles um more
polluting vehicles etc etc etc so so um
i think the still
at the moment seems to be high demand
for logistics
what perhaps will happen is that the
vehicles that use those and the way
those places operate will be a lot
greener than they would have been
either now or even you know five ten
years ago so that's the strand that
you'll be following throughout the
development is looking at
um
i know it all seems very abstract at the
moment but we have i think you mentioned
earlier the likelihood of the nature of
vehicles changing and
i think in terms of environmental
pollution etc etc so i just think
um
that i would like to know that there are
did it and i think i said this last time
that there are definitely people out
there who are definitely going to want
to use these units and i think that part
of this plan should consider
um
whether or not they will be attractive
if the clean air act does impose um
any any kind of extra cost i suppose so
i'd just like to know that it's part of
the plan going forward and that that
we're always moving towards something
that is going to be used and usable
um it's just that i haven't heard it
mentioned at all and it seems quite
relevant to me yeah yeah and i guess if
it if it helps at all um the places for
everyone plan and certainly our
subsequent local plan would aim to have
planning policies that would be able to
be applied through the planning
committee
to ensure that new developments as they
come come come on stream are um you know
do take proper account of of issues of
you know um carbon impact and so on
probably much better than we're able to
do at the present time because you know
we're relying on on older policies and
national guidance and but certainly
there's no indica i've not picked up any
indication that the um
clean air issues will
will will dampen demand
what seems to be likely is that they
will change the way companies operate a
lot of companies of course already
thinking really carefully about their
carbon footprint so it's probably that
that will change rather than the overall
demand if you see to me i think if we
return to this in the future i would
probably like to see something i
appreciate you've probably got
incredibly
uh sensitive
octopus-like tentacles for picking these
things up and having that sense of
what's going on um but i would probably
like to see something
um that's um
perhaps more
carefully referenced perhaps with more
examples a little bit more body to it if
that's okay thank you very much look
we're gonna
we're gonna have time to
do the work um
and i think
the first stages will be the ongoing
design work and uh the public
consultation i think that will take
you know to take quite a bit of time for
us to
uh to to analyze and scrutinize
uh and then to make recommendations
uh so so that's coming up uh
you know in the not too distant future
so
so
come here
we have to know yes we have we believe
in the projects before we consult
well
yeah well we'll come to that
thanks for that
uh much appreciated
and there's a lot of work to be done how
do we know
um
so
um
can we now move on to item eight
and it's a response to the
budget scrutiny report
it was circulated to us
and i think it's over to you you've been
very patient
thank you i'm i'm learning not to mess
with the scrutiny committee this evening
so
well thank you very much for inviting me
back everyone it's it's good to see you
all again i did plug everything in
it's not worked so i can i trust it
you've got all the uh presentation in
front of you and i'll just take you
through it and i'm happy to take
questions at the the end
um so
in terms of um
yeah please if you want i'll start just
to save time in terms of what we're
looking to cover today um
i want to focus on the estimated outcome
for this current year's budget so not
the one that we agreed at council last
month but the one we agreed last
february
the look at reserves because i know that
you're keen to keep a close eye on
reserves that came through your report
to the executive prior to the budget
key budget risks that we've identified
and also a mention of the finance and
change board which has just been set up
move on to the third slide now which is
period 10
estimated outcome for this year and
you'll see that on this slide i won't go
into too much detail but it breaks down
the the variances for each
directorate
what i'd like to draw your attention to
is the six
um at the bottom the net revenue out to
variance six thousand pounds we are now
projecting that um that we will be um
under spent
that's right by six thousand pounds this
this year so we're we're going to be
keeping within our budget that was
agreed last february thank you
with 6 000 pounds to spare now in this
grand scheme of things in a kind of
budget of 179 million 6 000 pounds isn't
too much but it goes to show what work
has gone into um into the budget over
the past few months as we've identified
trying to um trying to bridge the uh the
gap which at one point was in the
millions for this year as we were
forecasting so i'll just wait to see if
alex can work his magic
or is it just fed up it
seems to be doing something oh yeah
there's something happening oh crikey
right
so
if i just go to slideshow it may not
work if it doesn't
no harp done
yeah no never mind if you've got it in
front of you let's let's keep the show
on the road thank you for trying um so
if we go into the next slide now um
it's looking at the underlying movements
within that overall out turn figure so
if i just draw your attention to the the
the first section under the table which
is movements across the periods
you'll see that
a lot of the um a lot of the positive
movements for us when i say positive i
mean it means it's meant we've met
towards the budget figure itself they've
come from the um the vacancy management
protocols that we introduced so apart
from outside of social care we put a
freeze on vacancies we refer to a lot of
vacancies through this system and that
has saved us
a million pounds
obviously that doesn't mean that we're
carrying a lot of vacancies which has
its own questions
but for the term in terms of this budget
it has helped us bridge the um bridge
the out turn gap that we were looking at
earlier this year
um there's been some savings in public
the public health contract um we have
had a windfall from trafford housing
trust you'll see
so um that that was um something to do
with vat sharing and it was 200 000
pounds which has been added into period
10 which is uh very helpful in terms of
pressures though where things have have
hit the budget beyond our expectations
when we set it
children's placements
there's been an increase in pressure
there of 1.116 million
we've seen increased demand in home to
school transport
um our strategic investment program has
fallen short of the original
target of over seven million pounds so
we've fallen short by 1.5
million pounds in the strategic
investment program i stress as i always
do that that program has delivered six
million pounds plus to the frontline
services this year through the the
approach that we take with that
there's been
the tail end of code kovid if you can
call it that that's uh had an impact on
place and central services
and we also had the pay award which was
finally confirmed um in recent weeks
which was an additional almost a million
pounds that we hadn't budgeted for last
year because we were under the
instruction to have a pay freeze um we
have now gone through that process and
that's taken from our contingency budget
um
in terms of the savings programme
you'll see that we're at this stage
almost two and a half million pounds
below the target that we set back in
february 2021 for our savings and income
proposals
um we've obviously done a lot of work
with that to try and look at what's
realistic and um
we've carried well some will be carried
forward to future years others we've
worked into the next year's budget so
that we're
we're taking a realistic approach in
terms of the savings and incomes targets
that we that we have in future
if we move on to the reserves now which
is um which is the next slide
this gives you an overall impression of
the reserves and how we expect to use
them over the next few years
you'll see that um there is a large
number of earmarked reserves um that the
total at the um
at the start of april last year was
148.43 million of which a lot were the
covet reserves which have been
they're they're already being us taken
for that that they so we should really
pay too much heat for them because
there's a use for them and they will go
towards that use um
as we move along the next few years
you'll see that our reserves
do
diminish
however
we are looking at the ways that we we we
use future reserves the way that we
we take those reserves and
in future and this will be coming onto
the finance and changing the minute
that when we next look at reserves we
won't be looking at to kind of do a
short-term bridging of a budget gap in
the context of a
pressure such as the covid situation
that we've just had we'll be looking at
using reserves as a kind of invest to
save strategy so we'll be looking at the
way that we can use those reserves and
make sure that they will bring future
savings for the council and help the
overall budget pressures in future
that's the approach we wish to take with
with reserves given that
um they are and remain low compared with
other local authorities it remains a
challenge for trafford and it has been a
challenge
for decades in trafford under different
administrations and so we will have to
watch how we use those reserves
carefully but as requested by scrutiny
we will continue to come back with
updates on each of those reserves
moving on to the risks that we have
key budget risks are the reset of
business rates and the fair funding
review now these have been showing up in
our reports for
all the years that i've been in the
position so quite a few years now and
they may be put back again but there's
something that we have to bear in mind
the financial impact of the
business rates reset
and also any impact from the fair
funding review that that we can expect
mentioned already the delivery of the
savings programme um
we've got to keep at that manage that
closely make sure that we do deliver as
best we can
the further we go into the era of
austerity the the more challenging it is
to meet savings projects but we will
continue to keep a close range of that
um in terms of the investment portfolio
again maintaining the income levels we
get through that and looking at
recycling opportunities for investments
that come to their end and how we we use
that money and recycle that investment
the fair price for care and more market
sustainability so there's a whole
conversation around social care the
sustainability of social care
um retention of people into that into
that service
that's something that we continue to be
mindful of
going on to the the general social
health and social care
review and um that we're expecting we
need more details on that
the high needs budget remains a situ a
place that is under pressure and we have
looked at addressing that this year
but they'll continue to be things that
we have to be mindful of with the high
needs budget our favorite friend that we
discussed last time i was here which is
inflation um currently last recorded at
5.5 percent you may have seen reports of
that heading upwards
um it is a worry the energy price again
has come to the fore in recent weeks
with the situation in ukraine in
particular and that has an impact on
many aspects of of of our council life
and frontline delivery
and
going back to the reserves obviously we
have used reserves in the past against
the context of covid
to
bridge budget gaps we're looking to move
away from that now and you look at
managing reserves
sustainably and making sure that we use
them to invest to save
okay the next slide slide seven is a
finance and change i call this a
statement um
i suppose there could be a bit more
flesh in in what i said in that slide i
i i can admit that but it kind of
introduces you to to to what we're
looking to do
um with the finance and change board and
if we go on to
slide eight
it gives you a timeline as well as to
where we're up to with that board so
there has been a briefing to executive
um we had our initial meeting
last week
where we were scoping out what we want
to achieve and the different working
groups within
the um in in the finance and change
board we've got a meeting
um coming up at the end of this month to
to flesh out the program further
and then from then on we will we'll be
looking at different work streams and
how best we meet the financial
challenges we face
in future years which obviously mean
meeting the budget that we agreed last
month that's going to come into effect
from april plus the 50 million pound
plus gap that we have over the next few
years as well so it is a big amount of
work and i dare say that scrutiny will
want to look at without me telling
scrutiny what to do because that's not
my role but scrutiny may want to look at
how you
see
and how the finance and change board
reports into scrutiny and how you get an
input there and with that
chair and vice chair any questions
thank you very much for that uh and it
sounds like good news that you've closed
that gap uh from the previous year so
thanks for that any questions just a
point chair if i may it's um but this i
think is an example we're looking at the
scrutiny review of the kind of
information we want to see scrutiny you
know um concisely presented by an exec
member who doesn't make you feel like
you've dragged them away from the
football so thank you to the thank you
to the executive member
and as you say there is we bit more
detail on this board
as you say but well done thank you i'm
not sure tom's very interested in
football you beaten me too i'm a lapsed
city supporter but i last went in about
1998.
thank you very much for the feedback and
i know that dave and graham really
appreciate that too yeah yeah
thanks very much
yes
it just jumps out at me um the vacancy
management protocols
so that means we're not
employing people where vacancies emerge
outside of social care we took a
decision
partway through the budget this year
when we were forecasting a considerable
gap at the end of the budget year
that we had to look at how we managed
that and one of the things that we
put in place was a vacancy freeze or
referral um if it was deemed necessary
but that was outside of social care we
know that social care we have to have
people employed and as i said as part of
the presentation
it's helped us meet the budget but again
scrutiny we may want to consider without
me telling you what to do
but you may want to consider the vacancy
managements that we've had and the
vacancy gaps and how that may have
impacted on the operations of the
council well my
specific concern was the well-being of
those people who are carrying the work
of those vacancies and i just wanted to
just to raise that that um
that i for one and i'm sure other
committee members you know do appreciate
that work but i i firmly believe in a
third day's pay for a fair day's work
and i don't like i wouldn't like to see
um
that particular
budget management procedure negatively
affecting individuals who are feeling
stressed stressed answers are overworked
within our department and whether we
could do something about that going
forward even if it's more in terms of
well-being management than actually
filling the gaps all right thank you
can i just quickly respond i just
completely agree that the well-being of
our
staff is in is increasing our number one
priority and as i said in my budget we
are nothing without the staff that day
in day out go out there and deliver
services for this council and there are
a number of things that we have in place
to
reward and assist staff but it's always
it's it's it's an ongoing
journey that we have to make to make
sure that we continue to be a
responsible and fair employer and look
after our staff
thanks chad and uh thanks um councillor
ross is it all right you've asked two or
three questions in one go and then you
answer them
on mass um you did thank you for
answering your question that you will
welcome scrutiny of the finance and
change board uh process um so a couple
of questions i believe trafford's part
of the bottom 50 funded
local authorities are there any updates
on that group's kind of petition for uh
greater funding
um
in the budget risks you talk about a use
of budget support reserves 21 to 23 at
nearly 23 million pounds is not
sustainable
if there's a concise explanation of that
i'd appreciate it because there's a
statement it sounds a bit alarming um
and thirdly relating also to
staff appreciation welfare and
well-being um
is there an assumption of what in 2223
or 23 24 the
settlement might be for
um staff wages because based on current
inflation it sounds like we've just
awarded our staff a four percent real
pay cut
thank you
i will make a start answering then dave
may come in with a couple of things um
in terms of the
the the lowest funded local authorities
i've not had an update
yet i know we were we were
during the budget process we had written
to the uh secretary of state michael
gove
um about the situation and how we wanted
to see a
well an uplift basically which would
bring people up
to um to to a fairer setting for you
know so i think it was like a threshold
basically which is kind of a
contradictory thing to what i've just
said was kind of a threshold that we
would be raised to
which would have benefited us by
quite a few million pounds i don't have
a figure on top of head but maybe dave
will have that um in terms of the
reserves um
we've used reserves particularly
over the covered couple of years that
we've had
to
bridge our considerable financial gaps
we did that
because this this was a unique event it
was a challenging event you will have
many of you have seen the financial
impact that uh kovet has had
but with reserves once they're gone
they're gone
and it takes time to replenish them and
we do look to replenish the reserves and
you'll see there'll be some work that we
do with any out turn that we get to
replenish our reserves into the next
year so that's why we've had a change of
approach and that's why the continuing
to use the reserves as we had been doing
it's not sustainable because we don't
have that level of reserve there
the staff settlement i actually did look
up a few weeks ago and i'm kicking
myself because i did have that figure
but i think and dave will have that yes
it is below the current inflation
rates
um so yes the real term consequences of
that as with many people getting a pay
increase um
this year is that they will face a cost
of living cut um
and you know just talking about
inflation there was some work done and
published earlier this week about how
the lowest paid are looking at 10
inflation rate um which just shows how
we need to get inflation under control
and it's a situation that this economy
hasn't been in for 30 plus years so it
is a worry and i think there'll be a lot
of people across the board whether they
work in public sector private sector
their pay increase this year
will not be a real terms pay increase
but dave will fill in any gaps i'm sure
um
yeah i thought in terms of the
the what we're doing with the um boston
50 funded councils yeah we haven't had
any feedback from that yet but um
in the final budget report the gap is if
we were brought up to the average
something like an extra 20 million pound
for us so it is a considerable issue for
us
and then we're trying to address from
that um in terms of doing budget
sustainability the the use of reserves
um as councillor ross has already said
once they've gone they've gone um
so we have you to utilize the uh out of
the 23 million
uh about 15 million was due to one off
covey pressures uh that we managed to
accumulate so it reserves from brexit
grand news grants
and grant support from
the previous financial year so that
that's quite quite a chunk of that
of that reserve but given the gap going
forward
of um
18 million pound
over the next three financial years um
it's is a serious issue that we cannot
sustain that level
um of of um use of reserves um and so we
need to get to sustainable budget
savings and in terms of the pay award um
it has been settled at 1.75
for 21.22
there's been no
uh discussion yet on communication in
terms of the 2223 pay award i did ask
the question yesterday myself um
we have assumed a budget um
in the mtfp two percent pay award
which um giving the indication of
inflation does sound it's going to be
pressures within that area as well in
2223
thank you um
comprehensive answers both of you uh we
could um request that whenever you get
the outcome of that request to uh
michael gove on the bottom 50 funding
thing if you've got a written summary of
the response and outcome thank you
dan
thanks joe i think i've had the response
already from
michael gove passed me by
by the financial director so do ask him
um
but um the finance and change board
sounds like a serious piece of work with
massive implications for this council
and when we've already been making cut
year after year since 2010 and the
financial director says i don't know
where else we can make savings
how difficult a job is it going to be
for the council
it's going to continue the difficult job
that the council has been doing now for
well since
may 2010. um
it it will be in it also it's going to
be challenging we have
reshaped adapted and i know services
that we did have in 2008 when i was
started as a counselor a lot you know a
lot has changed many services have been
cut over the past decade many have been
shaved
so yeah the statutory obviously is there
and it continues to be the bit that
survives in the bit that we we maintain
and
bring forward i think
it will be challenging but i am feeling
optimistic about the work that this
finance and change board can do it's
bringing together the corporate
leadership team it's working with
other leaders across the across the
local council
there will be ways of looking at things
differently even at this stage
12 years in there'll be ways of looking
at things differently doing things
differently working with agencies much
better than we do because it still
amazes me how different agencies
including say trafford housing trust we
seem to work in
silos very much still there's a lot of
work that we can continue to do to
provide services for our residents but
have it a lot more joined up so
there will be yeah
it's going to be a very interesting
program to work on and i think
when we do have some firm plans coming
together
i think it would be a good opportunity
to invite me back invite people other
officers connected to the board back to
have a look at what we're doing so far
and a lot of these will then feed into
the general budget process
anyway anyway and that'll be from the
autumn onwards so i know it's a bit of a
word soup that i've just given you there
but i hope you
you see it's a serious piece of work
we'll be treated to taking it very
seriously and we'll be doing our best to
protect frontline services as much as we
can
right it's no
oh
sorry i just wanted also to thank on the
detailed response we got by email from
the last questions um to screw to neon
on the pressures on energy i mean you
mentioned it in your speech but you've
given
two and a half pages of detail here it's
thank you yeah and i don't know how much
i'm allowed to say about it but that
that is concerning isn't it
it is and and it just shows how fast the
world moves these days like when we set
the budget a few weeks ago that was
prior to the
russian invasion of ukraine and
though it looked like it could happen we
just didn't know at that stage and
you'll have seen what's happened to fuel
prices at that time unless
now more than ever we need to look at
decarbonization
let's get off the reliance on petrol and
fuel and look at the you know how we
embrace renewables more because we've
been left in a very vulnerable situation
as a country
in terms of
in terms of energy and reliance on
energy um
other thing to think about is the food
as well with the wheat situation in
in ukraine and the impact that that
could have
on some of the services that we provide
so yeah it continues to be an
interesting path
that we uh we walk but uh rest assured
we've got officers in place that uh that
you know
can
seem to be able to manage anything
without breaking a sweat and we're very
lucky in trafford that we have that
well graeme is off this week he's having
a well-ironed break so
[Laughter]
right on that note uh
it just remains for me to echo
uh what robert said i think um
every time that you come tom you you you
do it with a smile um and as if you
enjoy it so i think i think that's quite
quite refreshing
and i think you give precise answers as
well and then thanks to you and the team
in finance
um right we'll we'll move on to
um
yeah it's the budget scrutiny
oh no yeah
i'm looking at the wrong one
item nine yes sorry yes uh scrutiny
review
right so
um
clearly we have done a review
uh of scrutiny uh panel was uh set up a
member panel was set up we had um
external advisors as well
and uh the outcome of that is this
report
and it has to come to this
committee full committee uh to
uh endorse the recommendations
um
so i'll just open it up like that
did you want to
sort of say anything more
uh thank you chair i think it's
the report self-explanatory the work the
the view panel's done has been a very
positive and beneficial process i just
want to highlight the second paragraph
in the summary which is around
the positive and effective scrutiny that
traffic council has and that when you
normally undertake a review like this
and i've done a number of different
authorities you are looking at culture
change you're looking at
changing executive and officer buying
into scrutiny and members training and
development
none of that is really required if at
all this is about process and procedure
and it highlights the positive work that
members do here and hopefully the the
recommendations in here will continue
that
um and tweak tweak the outcomes that
scrutiny can achieve
thank you yeah
yeah i think that was a positive aspect
of it but um you know
we we
we did look at it in in detail and i
think um
one of the main kind of recommendations
was to
you know consider how we can
have pre-decision scrutiny and
and i think how we can involve the
executive
in a more effective way
in terms of how we actually move forward
uh within you know making sure that our
work is is relevant um
uh you know to to the decision making
process
so
um
yeah
yeah as you've probably seen it went to
standards as well on monday and very
very positive response there as well and
people were really really pleased with
the
the report and
the you know the the recommendations
really i think the one that we we wanted
to
i personally wanted to pick up on the
members of the scrutiny was the
involvement of the public
yeah involvement which we are kind of
doing we did tonight didn't we yeah he's
an example of that so i think more of
that i think is it would be really
useful and important and involvement of
the public because it's it has been a
bit of a sort of behind doors
process for many many years scrutiny
hasn't it's not really involved the
public so i think if we're moving to
that health scrutiny yes
yeah i mean i think that sort of process
i think is yeah that's a really good
recommendation
um i i think um
it's been
ad hoc i think in the in the house
health has done it and i think the
children young people
service
have done it brought you know uh the
public
uh
and other experts
in as well uh particularly around
education and stuff
um
but yeah
sorry it was jedford yeah
thanks chair um
i really appreciate all the work that's
got into this uh there's a good report
with some really useful um
recommendations if i could make two or
three points there's a specific
recommendation in relation to
consultation with the public about
encouraging
public contributions to scrutiny through
social media
i see scrutiny as being sober considered
balanced review of stuff and social
media is often
a forum where who shouts loudest and
longest gets heard and is also a vehicle
for misinformation as we've seen playing
out rather tragically elsewhere so i
would recommend that we do not
seek
public
inputs to scrutiny through social media
um
secondly um
there's a really
testing time scale here that says this
will kick off in 2223 that's imminent is
there a and most of the value comes from
setting off on the right foot at the
beginning of the year so is there a plan
to not only approve this report but turn
it into action that caesar's setting off
in 2223 or is that not realistic
thank you
can i just come in on that first point
if i may yeah i think there's ways of
doing social media
and i think it's appropriate to say the
council should do it on its channels
properly we are having a process by
which you can input like this not that's
not necessarily to say you know comment
below all your comments about trafford
and anything you happen to be selling
you know i think
i think it's just a case i took it to
mean that it's just a case of the
council making people aware via social
media that this is going on
no no it talks about asking the public
to contribute to scrutiny through social
media not giving information
thank you chair i think on the first
point what what
what you'd be looking to achieve is
highlighting the work of scrutiny and
encouraging residents to engage with
scrutiny i agree you may get 50
suggestions and 49 of them are not
really suitable or appropriate that's
why you've got a topic selection
criteria so it's not just he who shouts
loudest he or she shouts labs gets
through it's around you've made that
suggestion we've looked at it
all of this around working with the
executive working with partners around
giving scrutiny information around what
topics to look at and then there's a
criteria to narrow down the power to
pick a topic still sits with this
committee or the other respective
committees so it could suggest anything
does not mean you are committed to doing
anything and as i said there's a
criteria there to help you identify if
there is a genuine community need and
obviously you could pick that up
around
you know getting started
um
i think the intention is to try to
begin in the new
municipal year
and it and i think it starts basically
working with the executive and the
leader uh to look particularly around
pre decisions so so
um we we would
need to look carefully at the forward
plan and all of that yeah and john
just to come in on that
in the anticipation of the assumption
this report would be agreed tonight work
has been undertaken to get us ready
there is actually a line in the report
on page three one point three which says
we'll take this report to annual council
we're actually taking the council next
week we were ready faster than we
thought we were going to be so we're
actually taking it next week
um again it was subject to confirmation
tonight that that report then confirmed
otherwise it's still draft at the minute
and so yes we're confident we will be
able to get this done we've had some
conversations with the executives so
they're aware of what scrutiny is
proposing and again they receive that
positively it goes to the executive on
monday next week
and again we'll go to scrutiny um sorry
council week after so yes we will be
able to hit the ground running for the
municipal year yeah
could i just before we move on to
another question the specific thing
about social media you've replied saying
this is i was asking the public through
social media to say what should we
scrutinize
if that's what you mean can that be
explicitly put into the report because
saying greater use of the council of
social media to obtain resident input
and communicate in the progress that
could mean resident input into we've
decided we're going to scrutinize x now
give us your views on x and i would
counsel against that
yeah i mean i think
i think it's a fair point
that you make
it wasn't my
thinking anyway that that we can just
throw it out to anybody in this say
right well you know they they pick a
topic and
and that's agreed because it doesn't
work that way does it and but i don't
think
it's meant to be like that i i think one
one of the positive outcomes of scrutiny
is around engaging with residents and
why i would always champion as the
statutory scrutiny obviously that the
best way for residents to engage in the
scrutiny process is through elected
members however i do think there is an
expectation these days that we use
social media we use our communication
platforms to try and engage residents in
terms of areas of community concern and
things around
those natures so some authorities do it
by putting
adverts in the local newspaper uh i've
worked at an authority where we spent
literally thousands trying to canvas
general public topic suggestions you've
got next to nothing and if what you did
get was people's hobby horses which
again once you put them into the
selection topic criteria were never
chosen because there were other areas of
yeah just for clarity that's not what
i'm talking about i'm talking once it's
been decided what has been what is going
to be scrutinized do we encourage people
through social media to contribute to
that process so
both of you have replied about how we're
going to select i'm not talking about
how we're going to slide i'm just
concerned that once we've selected we
say we're going to talk about x we
invite inputs through social media
that's what i'm asking you to specify
not to be the case yeah i think the idea
behind the recommendation chair is to
engage public participation in the
topics that have been selected that is
one of the fundamental principles of
scrutiny is the topics that are chosen
we try and engage with stakeholders in
the public so this is around advertising
what we are going to do that tonight we
are going to have this meeting and these
are the agenda items come along and and
listen
so that's the idea behind it
yeah down
thanks cheer i think one of the most
important um points is it's a 8.1
um evolving scrutiny and the annual
review that will be held each year to
see if things are working
um and to
you know have that kind of process where
you audit it each year to see if you're
achieving what you want to achieve so
the social media piece could be part of
that review you know has it worked are
we getting the responses we want so i
think
you know the processes that we're
putting in place are really good and the
review panel each year will kind of help
us progress in a really strong way so i
fully supported
there are some new sort of um
suggestions in
in the report and
you do have to tread carefully and and
how how you actually
you know go about this um
but
i think
um
there's enough in it
for
significant change
that
we can
you know hopefully bring through
throughout the year
um
and
and i do rightly say
and of course it will be reviewed at the
end of the year and i think you know how
we've actually done that i think the
other thing
that has has been said
uh previously
is
um how we
monitor the actions
how we actually deliver
what you know to to to the executive our
recommendations and how they respond to
those recommendations
and i think that has to be tightened up
um you know in a clearer way
um
so yes louise
i just wanted to respond to council
proctor just to say um in terms of
consulting with the public it is it is a
really important aspect of what we're
doing to some extent of course when we
speak to um
members they are reporting on issues i
think it was jed did it not it's not
kevin
yeah she did initially yeah
and just to say that you know when we
talked when we talked to other members
mostly what they are reporting to us is
what residents have reported to them so
it might seem like
a bit of a circuitous route to find out
what residents concerns are but it's
also quite a direct one and it's also
sort of um a really useful way of
approaching it because
um
we've got a lot of members representing
broad areas and we if we're seeing
issues repeated across the borough then
we know that the the concern is more
significant and
if we have to get around to looking at
the
egyptian travel report that was
something that we picked up from them
that was one of the approaches we took
to that
so um
so we do recognize that we wanted to
speak to to the public more directly but
we also regard that the ward board
members um are reporting back on
residents concerns as well so that's one
of the ways in which it does it and i
think interestingly at the bottom of
page eight there are suggestions about
how um
how records of issues are recorded and
that will also include where the initial
um
questions were raised that we address it
as scrutiny so that will be something
interesting to look back on so we can
actually evaluate and assess how much we
did respond directly to the public
whether those that's where our where our
questions the scrutiny were coming from
which is something we haven't been able
to necessarily do so there's definitely
room for
um
both making sure that we do more of it
and checking how much of it we have done
at the end of the year so it is two
processes in one really that will
hopefully keep it moving forward and
making us even more responsive to the
public
thanks
yeah just briefly i mean about the
social media thing it clearly says
scrutiny should explore and experiment
with ways to allow greater access
openness and involvement with the public
i think that's one of the first things
that you know obviously i think we
should take that as a priority if i'm on
scrutiny next year um this year i mean
um to look at because i think that's i
think it's for me that's the big gap in
in what we do at the moment is that that
engagement with the public and i just
wanted to say that being involved with
this was a really positive experience
for me and i wanted to thank everybody
because it's i learned so much about
scrutiny and the role is greatly through
it and i think we've come up with some
really brilliant recommendations which
hopefully we can
start doing to tighten up what we
already do
thank you
and that has been
devised by the test and finish group who
i think
works well it's an interim report and
has suggested a number of
recommendations
uh to go to the executive so we can
catch it before
um
you know we we finished for further
um
can i just say on this chair it's all
i've read through it looks good very
great work the training i thought was
very worthwhile and interesting
and i fully endorse all the
recommendations
[Music]
just for my uh information and
clarification so in other proven this
does this now go to exec for exact
response thank you
yeah i fully endorse that i think it's
really really really good uh report um
and i think recommendation two will
certainly be something that the exec and
the officers will need to
get their thinking apps on and any
advanced time that they have of that is
good
now this is just for a
committee for committee members to put
forward
just as a point of order on this given
what we've just discussed about the
whole set in 2223 as a strategic piece
this that it was me that wrote the
proposal that you've just described i
think that would need to
wait until that process is in place and
it feed into the hopper of possible
issues
yeah
but i think given that strategic
approach with a hopper of
sorting hat or whatever then it makes
sense to put it in make sense put into
that if i could just um
if i could just um indulge uh the chair
since i put that proposal in um united
have come out publicly saying they're
going to potentially redevelop the
ground i've looked at the reporting on
i've looked at the reporting on that and
they're quoted twice saying what we
really want to do is make sure the
experience for the fans is fantastic and
not mentioning the experience for the
people who are held hostage around it so
whatever um happens in my the original
proposal a look at how the council
responds to that and what um
[Music]
protections are put in place including
all the stuff that put in the original
proposal i think would be something that
we would want to consider for 22 23
things yeah i i absolutely agree with
you i did read that
statement that they've put out
and
what they're looking they
they want to consult
first they've not decided and they're
getting
uh
some
uh advisors into
to look at what the best thing is to do
and these kind of two options
not
built build a new stadium
whilst the whole stadium is still still
up so they can continue to play
and
the other option it seems is to build
over the railway line
um
to to extend the capacity and
refurb the existing one so they haven't
said that they've decided yet
i suspect it will be a new build but
they did say all the things that jed
said about the community make a great
experience blah blah blah blah so it is
something that it's probably better for
us to hold back and when they
you know begin that consultation process
we could bring them in here
so so that would be a good thing to do
but that's for us in the future
yeah so we'll leave that then for now
right so i think that brings us to
urgent business which i don't have any
um
and
that concludes our meeting and can i
thank you all
uh for your
um
for your company tonight and uh the
involvement and uh the fact that this
will be the last meeting of the
municipal year
um
you know a double thanks to ev everybody
who has contributed so much uh over the
last year a particular
thanks to the vice chair rob who will be
leaving us
and
i think he he will be suddenly
missed on the council
because he does
show a lot of
challenge
to us it always has done
thank you
and and
obviously
[Laughter]
yeah
so i i don't know you know
nobody knows really at this moment in
time what the new committee will be but
uh i thank you all
you know for your patients and uh all
the good work that you've done you know
the year and the officers i have to say
um
who are very very important to us
so have a safe journey home yeah